قال سامح شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري ان
هناك رغبه لتطوير العلاقات مع تركيا
واستعاده زخمها على كل المستويات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه واضاف شكري في مؤتمر صحفي مع
نظيره التركي مولود شاويش اوغلو في
القاهره ان بلاده تتطلع لفتح قنوات
التواصل بين الاجهزه الحكوميه في البلدين
ان شاء الله
الاستمرار التواصل والتنصيف مع معالي
الوزير ايضا فتح قنوات التواصل فيما بين
الاجهزه الحكوميه
واستمرار على اعمالنا بشكل كثيف حتى نصل
الى ما نتطلع اليه سويا من
استعاده هذه العلاقه الهامه تحدثنا
بما هو
الخطوه
التي
تؤدي يؤدي اليها هذا المسار وتكون مؤشر
لتناولنا الكافه القضايا
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه تركي مولود شاوش
اوغلو انه بحث مع نظيره المصري سامح شكري
مساله اعاده السفراء من جديد بين البلدين
واكد تشوش شغله خلال زياره للقاهره هي
الاولى لوزير تركي منذ عشر سنوات انه على
يقين من ان العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع مصر
سترفع سترفع الى اعلى مستوى في اقرب فرصه
ممكنه
بحثت مع اخي سامح شكري مساله اعاده
السفراء للبلدين من جديد وما يمكننا فعله
بشان هذا الموضوع في المستقبل القريب
اضافه الى تقييم العلاقات والخطوات التي
من الواجب اتخاذها انا على يقين انه في
اقرب فرصه ممكنه سنقوم برفع علاقاتنا
الدبلوماسيه الى اعلى مستوى ممكن